Krefeld eine Stadt am Rande des
Wahnsinns tatsächlich will man hier
generell Tempo 30 einführen und uns
rechtschaffenden Porsche Hengsten das
Leben zur Hölle machen und wer hatte die
irrsinnige Idee Joachim Heitmann
Krefelder Fraktionschef der FDP what
man junge junge junge Junge sie machen
Sachen wissen gar nicht mit dem sich da
anlegen in der Partei ja natürlich sind
mutiger Mann muss man in der FDP immer
sein aber auf einer Seite werden wollen
sie nichts mehr in der Partei ne ich
werde auch nichts mehr nachdem ich das
gemacht habe werde ich nichts mehr gut
muss jeder selber wissen ne klar da
wollen wir mal ne ja Tempo 30 ist das
ihr ernst oder ist das ein neuer Versuch
die FDP als Spaßpartei wieder zu
etablieren nee so spaßig ist das gar
nicht denn die Reaktion ist ja durchaus
unterschiedlich ja gibt auch
Parteifreunde die sagen was machen Sie
denn jetzt erhalten Mann Verräter gibt
ja schon weiter an der Autobatterie ja
genau ja aber jetzt sagen Sie mal hier
ist überall Tempo 20 Tempo 30 sie haben
doch schon mehr oder weniger schon
halbieren Willen bekommen was ist denn
so warum sind denn da so widerständig
denn wenn wir jetzt die richtig
Geschwindigkeit einführen würden könnte
ich die ganzen Schilder doch abnehmen es
wäre für alle Beteiligten auch für die
Autofahrer viel schöner wenn sie wüssten
grundsätzlich Tempo 30 dann wird sie
nicht permanent irgendwelche Knöllchen
bekommen hier endet jetzt Tempo 30 okay
ich weiß nicht ob sie ist
ich fahre ein Porsche
ja da guckt ja was Porsche Cayenne
120000 Euro
ich habe das schon mal angetippt als ich
Mitglied einer Bezirksvertretung in
Krefeld war zum Erstaunen meines grünen
Kollegen ich habe deine Vermutung wenn
das nicht natürlich dieser dieser
rot-grüne Wahnsinn der so um sich greift
oder so dass dieser Virus dieses Virus
sie mittlerweile auch schon erreicht hat
und dass sie aus solchen Beweggründen
jetzt auch für Tempo 30 sind schon vor
längerer Zeit mich ja mal mit dem Thema
beschäftigt hatte bin ich da nicht viral
getroffen kein modisches Thema sonst
sind das Überzeugung für Tempo 30 aus
Vernunft früher hieß es freie Fahrt für
Freiburger was ist daraus geworden ne
ich als Porsche-Fahrer werde da dauernd
nur koordiniert ist doch ist doch
scheiße Herr Altmann aber ich bin ich
bin auch so geladen ich bin bereit
soweit haben oder was alle machen jetzt
hier ich habe ja Tomatensaft ich könnte
jetzt genauso wie es mit dem Gemälden
ist könnte
so Herr Heitmann ja ja da geht in der
Stift ne sie fährt hier mit dem Fahrrad
mit dem Helm und so und glaubst bald
gehört mir die ganze Stadt also wenn man
sich die Frage stellt in
Stundenkilometern ausgerechnet wie hoch
würden sie das Tempo der FDP bei der
verkehrsreform einschätzen
zur Zeit Null ich versuche ja das zu
steigern dass wir vielleicht dann auf 30
kommen um dann die entsprechende
Änderung der Straßenverkehrsordnung
durchzusetzen in dem Zusammenhang wäre
30 natürlich schon irres Tempo ne ja so
Herr Heitmann da sind wir ja ich wünsche
Ihnen alles Gute hoffentlich überleben
das ganze ich versuche
und dabei bestraft der Lindner so gerne
ach so jetzt auch noch Gott mein Gott
man darf gar nichts mehr als Porsche
fahren ist doch scheiße man
ich bin gegen Tempo 30 deswegen wird das
Auto jetzt hier stehen ich habe es
festgeklebt wir sind die letzte Porsche
Generation es hilft nur Protest ist auf
meiner Seite
hast du ein Herz für Porsche fahren okay
Bruder okay
gib doch noch Hoffnung
[Musik]
wir haben gesagt die soll man den
Lieblingswitz erzählen das mache ich
gerne also kommen ein Pferd Jeff Bezos
und der Papst in eine Bar sagt der
Barkeeper abonniere endlich den
verkackten heute schon Kanal also geht
doch